décision n'est pas encore tout à fait
prise l'embarras cet embargo ils
devraient ils pourraient annonce être
annoncée à demain officiellement de leur
communiqué final voilà saisissante
juillet encore sultats d'imagés des
européens exactement alors l idée ce
sont quatre pays qui poussent un les
états unis le royaume uni le japon et le
canada et l'union européenne et donc
avec elle ses trois représentants au g7
la france l'allemagne et l'italie
restent beaucoup plus prudent de vous
venez de le dire le chancelier allemand
olaf scholz affirme ce matin qu'il
faudra d'abord consulter l'ensemble des
vingt-sept des pays de l'union
européenne charles michel le président
du conseil européen explique qu'il faut
se méfier des fausses bonnes idées si on
veut et ne pas se tirer une balle dans
le pied en voulant sanctionner la russie
on risquerait de se sanctionner soi même
mais pourtant un tel embargo pourrait en
avoir un impact sur la russie alors
d'une certaine manière oui damien parce
que la russie c'est d'abord le deuxième
producteur mondial d'or au monde
derrière la chine l'année dernière ça
représentait un peu plus de 15 milliards
de dollars d'exportation dont 90 % vont
vers les pays du g7 est en très grande
partie il faut savoir vers la vère le
royaume uni londres abritant la
principale place financière mondiale des
matières premières en réalité 15
milliards de dollars ces cinq pour cent
seulement de la totalité des
exportations de la russie dont beaucoup
moins que le gaz est beaucoup moins
aussi que le pétrole qui sont les deux
grandes sources de richesse de la russie
et puis à moscou s'est servi de son or
depuis le début de la guerre et même
avant pour soutenir sa monnaie son
économie la banque centrale achète de
l'or sur son marché intérieur pour
constituer ces réserves de change et
donc remplacer peu à peu le dollar elle
en détient aujourd'hui à plus de 2000
tonnes soit 140 milliards de dollars ça
a permis à ce que le rouble la monnaie
russe qui avait beaucoup chuté dans les
premiers jours de la guerre remonte et
soi même aujourd'hui plus fort qu'au
début du conflit et puis le gouvernement
russe n'a pas attendu la décision du g7
pour soutenir son marché d'or de leur
intérieur or il a supprimé la tva pour
encourager les particuliers à s'en
procurer et alors cette décision en tout
cas ses sanctions sur leur russe si
elles sont appliquées ça risque d'avoir
évidemment un impact sur le prix du
métal jaune et d'où justement cette
prudence des européens dans le contexte
de l'inflation actuelle où tous les prix
montent à tous les niveaux le prix de
l'or avait atteint un record juste avant
le début de la guerre en ukraine à un
peu plus de 2000 dollars l'once mais
depuis il s'était plutôt stabilisé
autour de 1800 dollars ce matin vous
voyez le prix est en légère hausse à
centre un peu plus de 138 dollars l'once
mais évidemment si la décision devait
être confirmée ce pot au secours il
pourrait grimper ce qui serait une bonne
nouvelle pour ceux qui ont acheté de
l'or lorsque le taux était plus faible
mais mauvaise nouvelle pour tous ceux
qui projettent d'acheter des bijoux dans
les prochains mois ceux qui veulent se
marier par exemple n'avait plus le g7
s'est pas le monde il ya c'est une
inconnue c'est comment vont réagir les
autres pays ceux qui ne sont pas membres
du g7 et en particulier la suisse qui
est le premier importateur mondial d'or
pas seulement au risque d'ailleurs le
pays importe même un gros quart de la
totalité de leur mondial plus de 80
milles 90 milliards de dollars car la
suisse compte les principaux à raffineur
au monde qui purifie le métal précieux
qui est ensuite utilisé notamment dans
les montres ou bien dans les bijoux en
un certain nombre d'entre eux ont déjà
décidé sans attendre l'embargo du lait
ou l'éventuelle embargo du jce est de ne
plus acheter d'or russe mais il ya une
affaire qui agite la suisse depuis la
semaine dernière c'est l'arrivée
mystérieuse au mois de mai de 3 tonnes
d'or russe déjà raffinée de l'or qui
aurait pu provenir directement des
coffres de la banque centrale de russie
ou bien d'un oligarque et dans ce cas là
il pourrait s'agir d'une violation des
sanctions plusieurs ong appellent à
l'ouverture d'une enquête mais les
officiels en suisse ea vient que pour
l'instant il n'y a pas suffisamment de
preuves donc pas dans quel pour le
moment 3 tonnes d'or dont keith trois
temps donne moi la personne d'or qui
sont arrivés c'était la première fois
depuis le début de cette guerre
ils sont arrivés au mois de mai